clay um you guys have been booed each of
the last two home games obviously you're
not used to that um how do you how do
you handle that are you supposed to lose
sleep over
it this is the second straight game that
you guys were booed here how does that
make you feel when you hear
that
um uh I don't even know what to say
about it cuz
I want to be prisoners of the moment and
understand you know we're we're
obviously struggling there's nothing to
really cheer about so opposite of
cheering is booing might as well um I
don't take it any certain type of way
honestly I'm booing myself booing our
our you know team in my head because the
way we're playing so you know it is what
it is fans are going to react the way
that they want
um it's our job to you know give them
something to year but
we have not done
that